hey guys I'm Daniel and welcome to DLM
model lifestyle in this video I'm gonna
give you 15 hair care myths that people
still wrongfully believe
let's get to
hey if you're new here to my
channel subscribe and click the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos
now let's start with the first myth
hair products causes you to lose your
hair or to go bald... myth absolutely false
the fact is that your genes
nutrition and stress determines if your
hair will start to fall out not good
hair products well unless you put
something really strange in your hair
some people believe that if you cut your
hair it makes you grow faster that's
false your hair grows from their roots
not from the ends of your hair so
trimming your hair will not make your
hair grow faster now if you want your
beard or your hair to grow faster I've
added a few products for you in the video
description that will help you out
drying your hair naturally is better
than using a blow dryer...false, the fact is
that too much heat can damage your hair
but if you set your hair dryer to the
lowest heat setting it will not damage
your hair research has actually shown
that exposing your hair to water for too
long while air drying can actually be bad
for your hair because the interior of
your hair swells
if you wash your hair with a certain
shampoo and a certain conditioner your
hair gets used to them... false your hair
won't get shocked suddenly when you use a
different shampoo and a different
conditioner if you want some good
options for shampoo and conditioner I've
added a few for you in the video
description that you can check out
what causes dandruff? Dry scalp causes
dandruff... False, dry scalp doesn't cause
dandruff it's actually the opposite
dandruff is actually caused by too oily
skin so if you don't wash your hair
enough or if you just use the hair
products and you don't wash them out. if
you struggle with dandruff I added some
good options for in the video
description that will help you out
combing your hair over a long period of
time is very good for your hair... False it
is actually the opposite the truth is
excessive brushing can do more harm than
good because you can damage your hair's
outer protective layer by causing
friction and breakage over time
now some people believe if you wash your
hair too much it will become very oily
well guys it is actually the opposite if
you don't wash it enough it will become
oily and don't wash it every day
but every two or three days should be
enough now you've probably heard this
before but if you pluck out one gray
hair two or three gray hair will grow in
its place right. this is probably the
weirdest belief I've ever heard it's
just not true. if you get one gray hair
it just means that more will follow it's
just time. now sometimes when your hair
grows you get those split ends right
some people believe that you can recover
the split ends with good hair products
it's just not true it's probably because
of false advertising but it's better to
go and trim your hair
another myth that some people believe
wearing hats will make you go bald... it's
just not true
another myth, if you do not wash your
hair your hair will wash or clean itself
that's just so weird to believe it's
just not true. if you don't wash your
hair and your scalp you will just get
dirtier
and you probably heard this
one before as well. Nits and the lice
they like dirty hair... False they like
clean hair.
another belief out there is
that you're stuck with the hair
thickness that you're born with... it's
just not true guys the fact is your hair
texture can change with stress your
nutrition and your age as well
boldness
where does it come from? from mom from dad? Well I believed, because that's what
people told me as well when I was
younger. it comes from your mom's side
but the truth is you can't blame mom or
her family for you going bald it can come
from both sides from mom and dad side
smoking can actually make you go grayer
quicker they did some studies and they
found that people who smoke they're
twice as likely to go gray quicker than
those who do not smoke so that's another
reason for you I can throw away the
smokes
apart from cancer and for you guys that's
still in school a lot of guys in school
still think: "oh yeah I'm so cool if I
smoke". Smoking does not make you cool
your personality makes you cool now
remember I added those good hair product
options for you in a video description
down below so it's a bit easier for you
to go and check them out and do your own
research that's it guys if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
click the notification bell so you won't
miss the next video
that's it Cheers